To create this plot, we're going to use our gg plot
function.We'll pass it www likes received to the x variable, and
we'll pass likes received to the y variable. Then we'll set
our data frame equal to our pseudo Facebook users and then
we'll tell gg plot that we want that we want
a gm point or scatterplot. Now I actually forgotten something to
do here, I need to wrap my x and y variables
inside the aesthetic wrapper. So I'll add that in. Now you
might not have used the gg plot syntax,
but I highly encourage you to continue to use
it and to get practice with it throughout
this lesson. We'll be making more use of the
gg plot syntax in the next lesson, so
it's important that you really know it backwards and
forwards. Try making some other scatter plots with
different variables to get more familiar with the syntax.